if you're angry about the brexit delay
as many here on the Kent coast are in
these unexpected elections do you vote
for you Kip the party Nigel Farage made
great again or for Nigel Farage's new
brexit party you are here today at the
birth at the launch of a new force in
British politics
welcome to the brexit party Faraj led
you hip to first place five years ago in
the last European elections the prelude
to leaves 2016 referendum win but now
he's formed his own party breaks it and
you cape is under fire from its former
top salesman they've attracted a fairly
shall I say loutish fringe and we
certainly saw that we had the lead means
leave rally
Fannett voted overwhelmingly to leave
the EU but narrowly chose a conservative
over Faraj as their Westminster MP so if
you're weighing up the choice between
you Kip and the brexit party which way
you go I've come to the Royal Victoria
Pavillion now the largest Weatherspoon's
in Britain to start finding out I think
I'd be frozen for him to be quite honest
yes because I think that you've got some
issues they settled with a few things
that can actually weigh them down I'm
not always an actually an agreement with
the new kit leadership in the way that
they portrayed it and they have had some
problems in the past it is very
confusing but I just hope people will
want to vote for him again do you know
who you're going to vote for I won't
vote no not even for Nigel Farage or you
Kip know
no I wouldn't open oh you're gonna vote
for my husband not put in already
because with postal I parked him in for
you kit because I don't know about
Nigel's party it where what's it called
it breaks it so there's you keep or
breaks here which one are you gonna go
fisherman Steve Barrett's took part in
the famous flotilla up the Thames
when Faraj and Bob Geldof clashed the
you kept flag used to fly high on the
mast of his boat razor bill now he's
worried the splits in the leave campaign
will damage the cause of just getting
out three years now practically since
you voted no no one we haven't left
frustrated it's an understatement
I've had a gutful and I'm getting to the
stage where I'm wondering if we're ever
gonna get out what you're gonna do about
these European elections well we
shouldn't even be thinking about it but
personally I'm going to vote for whoever
I think can be the most disruptive in
Europe and I'm going to encourage
everyone else to do the same both
parties will be standing you Kippur
breaks it where do you go if they're
both standing in this area I'm going to
go with what appears to be the most
popular yeah I'm not gonna be loyal to
no Joe Faraj and I'm not going to be
loyal to you Kim Nigel Faraj may have
failed repeatedly to be elected MP for
Thanet South but he's still popular
locally this is his favorite fish and
chip shop is first I'll have a small
conscience please brilliant great thanks
you got an idea how you're gonna vote in
these elections it's difficult to say
because every party offers something
different going forward you look at
Nigel Rajas new brexit party you know
about that yeah yeah it's quite an
interesting stance that he's now taking
and I think I think it's needed I mean
what's wrong with it with you kid they
they were a one-time pressure group
almost that's how I think the majority
of people around here especially see
that you clips rather faded from the
political map here in successive council
elections so could brexit offer a fresh
start
free of UKIP's past and present
associations not all imports from the
continent are unwelcome as we found here
at the local bull or pétanque Club I'm a
big proponent of democracy and a voice
for the people but it needs to be a
voice for the people and not for one
individual on an ego trip the both of
these parties that claim to be in favor
of brexit are diluting their their
points of views by infighting amongst
themselves first opinion polls give an
early lead to the brexit party but
they're still five weeks to go until the
European parliamentary elections no one
wanted in the UK lots of time for voters
to change their mind the only certainty
is that no one is bowled over by the
idea of going back to the polls
Adam Bolton Sky News Ramsgate